once you've been in the market for 21
years and you look at that account and
you get to see it going up you're going
to like realize the value of investing
and that that's you know like the true
path to wealth
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want
[Music]
all right we're live what's going on how
was steph nice fancy pants background
yeah i'm in um a mechanism it's a fancy
uh it's a fancy pants office it's do you
know what mechanism is
i've heard of it that's the agency guy
who's a friend of yours i kind of know
him a little bit now
yeah they have uh an agency maybe a 200
person agency and they've got
as you do with agencies you've got very
fancy offices in soho and new york and
no one is here and i'm in the fancy
office here right now
all right good stuff yeah you missed
steph she was great as always so she uh
had a bunch of ideas it's like i know um
it's funny like we've had brayu be kind
of like our version of jamie like joe
rogan has jamie we've got to bray you we
now have dan
and you get a sense because at the end
of every episode we go oh dan how was it
hey i brought you how'd we do and um
and i feel like that they they both like
really keyed in on the same thing which
i don't know if listeners care in the
same way but like
the more random tangents we will go on
they kind of like they kind of love it
but they kind of hate it at the same
time whereas when steph comes on it's
like here are five ideas we're gonna do
idea one then two then three then four
then five what a jam-packed episode of
ideas and it's like you know me and her
don't have the same chemistry i mean you
have of like just being able to go on
random tangents or just kind of [__]
a little bit and so it's more packed
with info
but it's less packed with detours and uh
i don't know if that's good or bad but
it's packed with info so i think i think
definitely dan liked it i think a lot of
people will like it
but it's interesting to me how that goes
yeah and i've also noticed that a lot of
the things that i like the things that i
if i think it's going to be good i think
it tends not to be good and if i think
it's going to be bad
that's what i've noticed with the
content but the reason i wasn't here is
so let me tell you this funny story
about twitter so four months ago three
months ago i tweeted out that i wanted
to go drive race cars so one of my
2021's resolution was i wanted to do
more adventurous stuff so i want to take
a sniper class lesson i want to go
hunting
yeah i wanted to go hunting and kill
what i've eaten which i've never done
before
i wanted to do a cross-country trip i
did it and i wanted to go
learn how to do a race cars and so i
tweeted out i wanted to go to a driving
class this professional nascar driver
named parker hollered at me on twitter
and so me and jack butcher who's a buddy
of ours and a buddy of mine we drove up
here out to the country two hours
outside of new york to connecticut and
we took this class it was twenty five
hundred dollars it was at this place
called skip barber
skip barber driving driving class
we met the owner of the class this is a
business that uh that's a driving school
it does like 15 million in revenue crazy
interesting kind of cool it it it was
an ex-cop owns it like a like a new york
cop like in this like his was he's like
i'll just try it because i don't work as
a cop anymore it turns into a thriving
business he told me his goal is to hit
200 million in revenue in the next five
years
off this one track or like he has many
of these so here's what they do so it's
called skip barber racing it's like a
famous brand it's from the 60s he bought
it out of bankruptcy i imagine he paid
like low hundreds of thousands of
dollars and you bought the brand name
it's basically a website where they get
leads so skip barber if you're into cars
it's like a famous racing school he owns
the website and so people go and submit
leads at where they want to go and they
go and find like tracks throughout the
country and they rent like 20 days at
the track and they show up with their
tractor trailer with like 20 mustangs
that you can that they drive and then
it's like a traveling circus they go
from place to place to place to place
it was pretty interesting so what'd you
drive
it's by the way i know nothing about
cars so you're gonna say something and
i'll be like oh cool no no no no no no
it looks like a mustang but it's like
it's a race car so there's no seats
you're locked in you wear a helmet
you're locked in what about like seats
there's only a driving seat like the
inside it's like a it is a it's a race
car there's a roll bar there's no like
ac or radio or anything like that but it
looks like a mustang from the outside
anyway that's what it was crazy
fascinating business that's pretty cool
um while you were saying that you said
something about he used to be a cop
and we had talked about the retired the
mafia tours in new york business i'm
going on it a great idea so if you don't
if you didn't hear that episode it's
basically retired cop in new york takes
you on a walking tour of new york city
to the different like areas where the
mafia families lived it kind of tells
you stories it's like we all like crime
tv shows or whatever
and uh
and this is like basically crime tv
walking tour um and so you get to hear
all these stories i guess you're going
on it that's cool and we had said he he
had done over a million dollars in sales
on his airbnb experience uh of doing
this which is pretty freaking awesome so
um
this thing you're talking about though
uh i think there could be a really cool
version of that that somebody makes
which is basically a cops and robbers
like a cop chase a car chase basically
so they could just have a a driver who
knows what they're doing as the kind of
like main driver
and you get to be in a cop car like they
just take some junk cop car
and you get to drive that thing you get
to like be talking on the little radio
try to get their license plate and it's
basically like a
you know controlled
simulation of
a car a cop chase like a actual cop
chase you go you get them you spin them
out then you get out of the car and you
get like you arrest them as the end of
it and i feel like that would just be a
super fun and be a lot of people would
pay for that and the video of it
i uh yeah so we p i paid twenty five
hundred dollars for this i think i paid
an additional three hundred dollars for
a video for the video of course yeah
uh
man it was awesome it's fun it's fun to
do this stuff to get out of our comfort
zone and do exciting stuff uh so that's
where i was
nice uh okay i love that all right let's
do uh let's do some ideas i have an idea
that's kind of related to this
so i was watching
uh
dana white who's the president of the
ufc and uh he was doing this like
youtube video and he's like
boys
uh no not that one there was this one
who just goes check out how sick my
hotel room is right now in houston did
you see this yep and he had a
go
go ahead describe it and i'll tell you
the part if i remember correctly he had
a movie theater in his hotel room i
think he had a full or no half-size
basketball court yep that was painted
like the rockets basketball court with
the official scoreboard on the on this
on the wall and stuff and what else did
he have
he had a bunch of stuff so he had that
he had like a full gym like so you know
like hotels have a gym his hotel room
had a gym which is kind of amazing and
then he's got like whatever cool bed
bathroom full steam room but the thing i
thought was interesting he goes check
this out and he grabs this huge rifle
off the wall there's like a rifle a
shotgun sitting next to each other
and he was like this is cool it's like a
virtual shooting range yeah and then he
like and he pan they kind of pan over
they went over real quick so i couldn't
even really see what it was but in my
head i just immediately thought of
you've seen these like golf driving
ranges that are basically it's a green
screen
and then you swing a real club and you
hit a real ball into the green screen
and it like simulates
where it would have landed if you were
on a real golf course and um those are
like semi-popular so he's got this rifle
off the wall and i started thinking oh
that's kind of cool basically if you've
ever held a real gun it feels totally
different than like you know the duck
hunt gun or like an arcade gun like a
real gun has like weight to it it has
like a recoil if you fire the thing so i
was thinking somebody could probably
build a high-end
version of this niche business which is
basically virtual shooting ranges so you
have a either a screen like a green
screen or like a plasma like a big flat
train tv
and then you give them like
what feels like a real gun but it's like
a digitally enabled thing so you don't
have to have bullets and go outside do
all that stuff and i feel like somebody
could build a pretty unique business
doing that providing that either to bars
or even for at home stuff or corporate
events that's a fantastic idea have you
ever been to an indoor shooting range
indoor shooting oh like where the
target's there and you have the earmuffs
on or whatever yeah i got it okay it's
miserable so i've only got outdoors so i
the outdoor shooting ranges are fun
indoor shooting rains miserable
it has lights like a hospital and it is
so
loud
have you ever been next to like an ar-15
or something like you know like a huge
gun when it shoots it rattles your
neighbor so you're standing right next
to someone and it's not just loud but it
shakes me and it's a miserable unsafe
horrible experience i would way rather
do something fun like this over that
yeah so and i feel like because it's
digital you can do fun stuff right so
when i went to go shoot a gun for the
first time
i'm not into that my brother my
brother-in-law is he um you know we went
and it's like you're outside it was kind
of cold
you're shooting these like paper targets
they don't move
uh you have to stand still every five
minutes have to stop reload the [__]
gun takes time like just take a lot of
breaks in between the action the action
is fun but like there's a lot of other
stuff going on it was it was
uncomfortable and uh and i get that like
you know real man [__] not supposed to
be comfortable but guess what people
like comfort so um so i think what you
can do instead is you basically make a
souped-up version of the deer hunter
game where you get the digital gun but
it feels like the weight of a real rifle
or a real shotgun and then you have like
a digital scenario right you wanted to
do a sniper class or i don't know what
you said like a psychopath but like you
probably want to like simulate actually
like sniping someone at a like situation
in some situation like you can only see
part of their head they're really far
away or whatever so you could do that
instead of just a paper target so i
think this could be a good idea i'm sure
something like this exists but it's all
about
turning it into a business in a box
or a traveling circus like you said and
like coming up with a model that that
productizes this better i think it's a
great idea and i would love to i would
love to attend all right let's do
another one you uh can you pick either
one or one for mine this is a little bit
less of an idea but more of an
experience that i had so last week i
went down to nashville i had an
issue a few weeks ago where i had a car
problem i had to leave my car at the
dealer in nashville i went to go pick it
up and i started shooting the [__] with
the salesperson
they sold he told me this is this is a
mercedes-benz music city dealership
that's what it's called
they told me that they sold 200 cars in
june is that does that boggle your mind
i never really thought about how many
cars that is that's 20 million dollars
in car sales right in one month that's
crazy to me and so i went and looked at
what the figures were for uh what how
many cars are sold june to january
because i would think january or
february would be a slow month it's
mostly pretty steady
it's like 1.6 million on a high month
and 1.2 million on a low low month it's
not crazy different so if you assume
that the average sale price was a
hundred thousand dollars and then you
assume that they did 20 million dollars
for six of the months and 15 million
dollars for the other six of uh six
months that's 210 million dollars in one
location and then i was talking with the
guys who ran the the company who ran the
dealership they told me that they can
expect to make 10 to 15
profit on that does that kind of boggle
your mind that one location can do that
much in sales and was this like did you
feel like it was like an outlier
location like killer killer real estate
or something like that it's a mercedes
dealer in nashville and there's three in
the city so did i think that that's an
outlier
in one sense yes because they're selling
you know expensive cars so like it's not
like a hyundai where you're selling 20
000 cars but it's and it's also in
nashville there's probably 10 to 20
cities in america that are of equal
booming as nashville so outlier in one
sense yes but not crazy outlier and so i
got interested in this and so there's
this amazing website called open secrets
have you heard of that
i've i've heard of it but i've never
gone to it why do you you actually go to
it it's like wikileaks or something i go
to it all the time and here's why so if
you go to it you can go it's called open
secrets maybe opensecrets.org
and so i don't know if it's legal or if
it's customary but if you are a senator
if you're in the house of
representatives if you're in a certain
type of office in america
they typically disclose their income
taxes and also what their net worth is
and you could browse through and you
could see how much money they have in
different bank accounts you can see how
much money they have in different stocks
you can see how much money they value
their privately held business it's
incredibly fascinating so for example if
you google open secrets net worth
senators you'll see a list of the
richest senators and it will tell you
where their money is and you can click
it and in some cases if it's from the
90s for example if you go and look at
george bush's net worth you could
actually see it's it's still a
handwritten w-2 so it's incredibly
fascinating and i browse through there
uh a fair bit because i think it's
really fun who cares what if they're
politicians or not but what's
interesting is that they're incredibly
wealthy and you can see how do people
allocate money where does their income
come from how does that work and i
noticed that there was a fair bit of
people who made money through car
dealerships in congress and i actually
made a list of them so the first one
vernon buchanan he's out he's a
congressman out of florida 157 million
dollar net worth where does his money
come from buchanan automotive group
where they sell new and used cars in
florida and he assigned 50 million
i just go through this list i did not
realize these senators there's this many
senators that are this wealthy so first
the funny funny thing is there's the
richest and poorest so okay on the top
side you have mark warner richest
senator uh he's in virginia i think and
at 214 million
poorest senator poor alcy hastings in
florida negative 7.5 million dollar net
worth this guy is in a hall of debt this
guy is just and you know the the the
lowest one that is
non-negative let's see probably like a
hundred grand or something like a pete
dude or something i'm exporting all
these csvs this is gonna be great uh go
go on sorry so i went and looked at some
of the congress folks that were that
were
rich and it was vernon buchanan he owns
an automotive group he has signed uh
around 35 million of his net worth sorry
uh almost 100 million dollars of his net
worth to car dealerships ron williams
from texas net worth 67 million dollars
he had close to 10 million dollars
because he uh is part owner of a
chrysler dodge and jeep business john
campbell net worth of 23 million dollars
he owns franchises for nissan mazda ford
saturn and saab and mike kelly net worth
20 million dollars he assigned at least
five million dollars for his car dealers
it was incredibly fascinating so i dug
even deeper this nashville dealer do you
want to know who's the co-owner
who
nick saban the uh
coach
from university of alabama and he owns a
bunch of them he owns three four or five
crazy fascinating to me about the car
dealers and i i was just so curious as
to how the rest of them do and so i did
a little bit more research and i read
different interviews with car dealers
and typically they make about five ten
percent in profit but the secret is that
hey they have to make most of their
money from service and parts because
that's where the big margin is and b
there's actually
there's actually a lot of ways that you
can test this so you can do loads of
test advertising and they kind of do
this like mvp style advertising where
they'll advertise in different places
see which cars sell and then become an
importer or sorry a dealer of that
particular car uh i just thought it was
so fascinating about how these car car
dealerships work have you ever uh
like do you know anything about this
first of all you're on fire right now so
i just got to give you a little bit of
credit you're on fire right now i don't
know if this is jake the researcher i
don't know if this is sam the the deal
hunter i don't know what's going on but
good job i love this i love open secrets
i love the senator thing and i love the
car dealership thing all right so let me
just put that on the table
have i thought about this no but it's
been hidden in plain sight i grew up in
colorado and john elloway always had
dealerships it was like
everywhere and i just i never really
thought about it but like clearly the
guy was making bank on these dealerships
otherwise he wouldn't be spending so
much time and energy doing all these
little kind of marketing meet and greets
at his dealerships and
that combo of like local hero
car dealership i think has just worked
for a long time like in the movie little
giants i think the guy that's how the
guy had his money too is like
local football star you know car dealer
is like just like a formula that works
and um i know that like there's like the
guy who's who gets a lot of press during
um
whenever the toronto raptors do well
they have this super fan uh this sikh
indian guy who who uh shows up at court
side of every game nav back to you i
actually have him listed here so he
started as a hyundai sales person and he
eventually started owning a car
dealership and he claims his net worth
is 50 million dollars
exactly and he spends all of his money
traveling with the team and buying
courtside tickets to every single game
this guy's like a maniac um he goes to
every single game and he has for like 20
years courtside and he's like cheering
like crazy and yeah he started as a
salesman you're right um okay so this is
kind of interesting i want to share with
you a couple things that i can add to
this have you ever heard it and by the
way if you scroll down you can see all
the examples i have of people who have
made at least a billion dollars to car
dealers you see that this is pretty
impressive so the benson family they on
the saints
uh penske
wayne hazard you love that guy he
started with autonation yeah and he owns
uh he owns the miami dolphins yeah that
guy's a baller we should we should
feature him you know a lot about him um
well mark wahlberg has one michael
jordan has one all right that's pretty
interesting so that's cool i didn't
really realize that this is like one of
those franchises that you kind of want
to own
um i wonder if that's changing so in my
head i'm like car dealer isn't this dead
like aren't car sales just moving online
and then you have platforms like carvana
that's like become like a seven billion
dollar company of like buying cars
online so definitely some some of buying
cars moving online
um
but i but not all and so i actually ran
into this company called modal have you
ever heard of modal
tell me about it the url is just
modalup.com and uh a buddy of mine is uh
samir
uh this great guy samir bala he
basically
he was gonna do a startup and then i
checked his linkedin and he's like oh
i'm ceo of modal now i was like what the
heck you took a job and i was like if
this guy took a job this must be
an interesting business because he would
not go join a company unless he thought
this company had like really good
prospects and i trust his judgment and
so
i i should have invested i asked them to
invest i even made room and then i got
cold feet at the last minute for some
stupid reason but
basically
i think this is a great business what
they do is they basically
made it so that any dealer
it's like shopify for car dealers in a
way so it basically lets you sell cars
digitally and online so it creates like
a website a checkout button a buy button
that you can just send customers to that
that that want to buy from you it also
just like automates all the workflows so
like with buying a car when you go buy a
car you're gonna end up sitting in the
dealership for like an hour because
there's like the paperwork if you're if
you're doing a loan or a lease you have
to do even more paperwork
and then um
you know you just have to like collect
all these signatures and get all this
stuff to get the title in your name and
these guys basically turned all that
into software and they were growing uh
really really well basically going to
car dealerships and getting them to
adopt this software so that they could
keep up and compete with
the kind of like online only platforms
it's like hey don't don't stay stuck
in the brick and mortar only ways yes
you're a car dealership but you should
allow
some digitalization digital digitalize
your workflow and let your customers go
check out online and just buy products
and what they do is they actually claim
that they can you know boost sales by
like you know 30 35 or something like
that and it shortens the cycle time
because usually people take quite a
while to look through stuff
and they um they speed up the the
purchase price the purchase time as well
so i think this is a pretty cool
business that's going to be quite big
i i'm on board with all the digital
stuff i was just fascinating at just the
brick and mortar and it's i it's still
growing like crazy in fact there's loads
of data on this because
i didn't realize how impactful cars are
i mean of course i you know we all have
them but i didn't realize how they kind
of in in a sense are minor
maybe major players in the country in
our country and how we even develop laws
things like that and and so
there's all this data that you can go
and learn about this so the average car
dealership like the physical dealer the
average one in last year 2021 did 36
million or sorry year-to-date so the
first six months 36 million dollars in
sales
in uh just the average car dealer and we
sell something like um yeah but that's
like gmv that's like car sales so you
know they don't you said 10 10 to 15
maybe is their margin on that so that's
correct million you know take for the
for the whole dealership it's still
astounding and then if you can also go
and look at uh another website you can
go to it's pro republica and you can see
which lobbies give money to the
government for different laws car dealer
or the car lobby which there's like
eight of them they give substantial
amounts of money and anyway that's my
that's my segment on car dealers and
cars pretty astounding i was shocked by
it we can move on
you know what's cool by the way tesla no
no dealership model so bold move by them
to not have any dealers and in doing so
basically kept a lot of the profit for
themselves and went direct to consumer
they were the sort of first direct to
consumer car company uh that exists so
so good job bye bye elon
yeah and i could see that taking off but
the market is massive not everyone's
going to do the same thing um and so
there's room for everyone
for a lot of always holding it down for
for blue collar america i love it you
know in my mind it's just two coasts
squished together with some stuff in the
middle and you're like no no
the middle is there's a lot of beautiful
stuff in the middle and it's not all
just going away and becoming like fancy
tech right away not yet at least
all right uh let's do some more so look
at my topics here and tell me which
one's interesting spoon flowers one of
the most interesting things i've seen
lately had you heard of this before
spoonflower no no
check it out i don't even know the url i
think this is
they saw they sold for 225 million
dollars so i i got familiar with this
because
uh for a clothing company that we were
working on uh we needed to look at
patterns and i was like where do you
find patterns online and you can find
patterns in many places but one place
was spoonflower so this is
basically a marketplace where you have
on one side
designers who come up with like let's
say a nice floral pattern or sunflower
pattern
and then you can take those so like i
think your mother-in-law is doing like a
pillow business and so she can go on
spoonflower and say oh i really like
this fabric swatch
pattern
um i want to basically buy this pattern
and turn it into pillows i want to buy
this pattern and turn it into wallpaper
and so you can use it for all the things
that patterns go on wallpaper you know
like mats
pillowcases whatever different stuff
like that blankets curtains [__] like
that so it's this like niche marketplace
you most people haven't even heard of
and then you go there and you see it and
you're like oh this makes total sense
and so they sold for 225 million to
shutterfly
um i thought it was really cool and just
like kind of this niche product that's
been around for a while that's sold and
then i wanted to share also a growth
hack but what's your kind of like first
reaction to this i think this is
brilliant i'm looking at it right now
there's a few reasons why i like this
company the first is that i believe it's
based in north carolina i like things
that are not in silicon valley not in
the heart i think they're not in the
heart of uh
technology uh hubs i think that's
amazing
there's so many wonderful things about
this business it's just
i mean it's a win-win-win type of
company where where you help people make
money you help people get what they want
the company spoonflower makes a little
bit of cash i'm into it
right and it was started in 2008 so it's
been around for a while and it's one of
these that like like most marketplaces
marketplaces are extremely valuable when
you get them to work but they can take
time to work because you have to get
that to keep cranking the wheel
of supply and demand to get it to work
you need enough designs and enough
designers and enough buyers and then you
have to keep like do a lot of manual
stuff to make that work so one thing i
liked um this guy who listens to the pod
adam adam keisling i think is
how you say his name uh he was talking
about um
this deal and he was pointing out this
like uh this method that they used to
grow and he's like i'll just share with
you a couple things he pointed out so
spoonflower uh 3.3 million unique
artists
uh 4 000 new designs uploaded on average
every day so that's a pretty crazy scale
and what they did was they would do
design challenges and so
um spoonflower would host a design
challenge and then the top 50 voted
popular voted designs
would get featured as the winner's
circle and
it would get to the top of the website
and then if you go to the website you
click like you know oh let me see the
best halloween designs
uh that would drive like 95 of the sales
to a lot of the creators so it was kind
of feast or famine you would you take
your shot to get noticed but if you got
noticed you would get a ton of inbound
sales um for for those uh for those
contests right and there might just be
like a thousand or two thousand people
participating in each one and so i
thought this is a pretty smart model of
how they bootstrap the marketplace so
they're like all right
we need uh buyers want content for
halloween how do i get a bunch of
designers to make the right halloween
content and make it all make a bunch of
new ideas that are unique you can only
find them on spoonflower i'll host this
contest and the haunted contest winners
get like i don't know hundreds of
dollars thousands of dollars doesn't
have to be too much money um
and they get exposure through that
through that process and then he was
adam was sharing that like uh you know
food 52 that they used to do the same
thing when they were seeding their
marketplace of recipes right they had
chefs uploading recipes and then people
coming to download them
um they would they created a contest
called your best recipe using fresh
mozzarella right so give me your best
mozzarella recipe
and then you know they would get whole
foods to sponsor it and get a gift card
and then they're like the grand prize is
a thousand dollars right and so they
would keep doing these contests around
things that people were searching for in
order to see the marketplace with the
right content so i thought that was a
cool learning as well from this
this is amazing and what's even more
interesting or as interesting is that
shutterfly bought them
i i forgot about shutterfly i just
looked them up shutterfly i think they
got did they did they get de-listed they
were public they had a two billion
dollar market cap and like close to two
billion dollars in revenue right
and so one uh
that's a complicated that's a that's a
crazy space the show that where
shutterfly is so you know good luck good
luck to them
spoon flowers badass can we um
can i tell you something that surprised
me uh so so
the other day rihanna was named a
billionaire that's pretty amazing right
yeah
i think that's amazing and so
i i got curious i started working with
jake i was like what other celebrities
have gotten rich in ways that i wouldn't
really have known right away
and it kind of got i kind of got this
youtube this is going to be a youtube
segment right here 10 celebrities that
got rich not from their fame
well it's it is a little bit extended
from the fame but i'm gonna give you six
of them so the first you know who jimmy
buffett is you're not you're not white
so you may not be in a jimmy buffett
i've heard the name but if you said
point here's five old white guys point
out jimmy buffett i would just point to
the far right i have no idea so jimmy
buffett i don't even know how to just
explain them white 60 year olds who wear
tommy bahama do you even know what that
is yes i know that one uh okay white 60
year olds who wear tommy bahama love him
he's the guy who created a cheeseburger
in paradise that song so he also had
this album called margaritaville it's
all about the caribbean and being on a
boat and like living this like parrot
style life i think that's parrotheads is
what he's called so he's got
margaritaville it's a subsidiary of
cheeseburger holding company which is
pretty funny he's got 30 restaurants and
he has vacation clubs hotels uh a
retirement village and tequila
collectively the holdings do something
like two billion dollars a year in sales
is that crazy
then you also probably don't know about
this one this isn't in your wheelhouse
but dolly parton do you know dolly
parton is that his girlfriend who is
this
you don't know who dolly parton is
again i've heard the name if you showed
me five old white ladies i couldn't
point out dolly parton so dolly parton
was a famous country singer but she did
more than just country have you uh heard
the song i will always love you by
whitney houston yes she wrote that she
wrote working nine to five which has
been covered many times she's just a hit
maker but she was famous you probably
remember photos of her she's in her
probably close to 80s now 70s but she's
famous for having blonde hair and huge
boobs uh you definitely like remember
her she has famous phrases like you
wouldn't you wouldn't be you'd be amazed
at how much money it cost to look this
cheap she's got phrases like that but
she's actually a great person and she uh
has an empire person
well she's like you know
well she's like
she's known for her philanthropy and for
doing good she she gives back to the
community she seems like a wonderful
person and it's kind of a joke that she
looks cheap that's like her joke um
right but it's estimated that she has a
net worth of like 600 million dollars
and i was driving through the smokies
recently just two weeks ago and i drove
through gatlinburg tennessee which is a
small town in the mountains of tennessee
and right outside of that she has a
[__] theme park it's called dollywood
her name is dolly parton he has
dollywood there's rides it's a huge deal
it's amazing they've got uh just imagine
six flags but it's all about dolly
parton and it's called dollywood it's
amazing you know we're like 15 years
away from like
paul world in in la and it's the paul
brothers uh you know version of disney
world that's what's gonna happen here
they are our dolly partons of our
generation it could be so i'm shocked
you've never heard of dollyworth
dollywort dollyworld you've never heard
of that dollywood no no
it's a huge thing it's very big like
it's like a mini six flags it's not even
a mini six flags it's almost as big as
six flags and people in the south i'm
from missouri i lived in tennessee so
i'm kind of southern people in the south
are obsessed with it that's where you go
on vacation you go to dollywood and you
actually go to a lot of different
casinos in the south you'll see dolly
parton themed uh casinos casinos it's
crazy all right another one sammy hagar
that doesn't ring a bell either to you
does it nah this is just a humiliation
session god that's so funny van halen do
you know what van halen is i heard dude
you are
god that's so funny okay so sammy hagar
uh from van halen he sold a tequila
company for around 80 million dollars
and it was
a tequila brand and i'll just tell you
two quick ones you don't know any of
these people it's all just like white
basic people kate hudson you know i know
kate hudson but i see her
athletics written here she what does she
have to do with fabletics she helped
start it she was one of the co-founders
okay i didn't know that
crazy right uh your wife probably wears
it i mean it's like a uh
they they sell fancy tights right right
2020 revenue 500 million dollars wild
and then finally
she owns 20 of it yeah i know jessica
alba
yeah so 20 meaningful um and finally
jessica alba
started or helped start the honest
company it just ipo'd it's got a market
cap north of a billion dollars i believe
and her stake around 130 million dollars
it's pretty amazing right
i like it um yeah so what do what do you
think is like the best model so what do
we see here we saw like
entertainment so hotels uh casinos you
know like kind of like amusement parks
then we saw basically like makeup
company skincare company
you know fragrance company and alcohol
brand
um which one do you like or do you think
there's another one that they're
celebrities are sort of leaving on the
table
uh alcohol seems like the best conor
mcgregor recently did it he sold um
proper 12. i believe his steak was worth
around 100 million dollars i think
alcohol is the the best one because you
can charge 50 for a bottle of a certain
type of alcohol and there's a chance
that someone will want to buy that many
times a month so i think alcohol is
interesting makeup's okay i don't
obviously don't know anything about that
rihanna crushed it her brand is killing
it it's called uh what's it called fenty
and she's got she's got she's got a
couple brands they kill it but i think
alcohol is number one although i do
think that there's a world if i was a
lance armstrong and i've told him he
should have done this when he was on the
podcast if i was a lance armstrong a
michael phelps something like that i
would 100
partner with a hotel brand and do
fitness focused hotels and try to have
branded a branded pool or a branded pool
instruction that you could do in that
pool like a workout or do a cycling
branded hotel i think that would crush
and i think you could make money for
every year for 50 years doing that right
yeah i think doing something that's on
brand is kind of the key like sam harris
doing this with a um
sam harris did this with a
uh a meditation app right because that's
what's on brand for him if sam harris
came out with alcohol or like
you know like a skincare line
no thank you but sam harris with the
meditation app that could work and i
think that thing prints money
it does and so i've heard um all right
you want to do a few more
yeah dan has one on here by the way uh
george clooney making a billion dollars
with casa amigos uh tequila um
somebody told me this story i i didn't
plan to say this i don't know if it's
true or not i might be making it up
uh
george have you heard this george
clooney giving his friends a million
dollars each
no
so
so george clooney uh this is the story
so so george clooney um
at one point in time he was like you
know when i i think he was thinking like
when um when i retire when i die like i
want to basically give some of my wealth
to my friends because these friends are
like some of the best people in my life
i used to sleep on their couch when i
was like trying to make it and they
really like helped me in one way or
another all these friends have helped me
and then he decided like okay why am i
gonna wait till i die like that doesn't
make any sense and so he invited them
all to like a dinner or like a dinner at
his like whatever cabin or something
like that i'm making up a lot of these
details but what i was told was he
invites them all to a dinner
and he brings
14 briefcases
or like suitcases a tumi suitcase
actually
each one was filled with a million
dollars in cash and he invited them over
for dinner and he gave each of them the
suitcase and they each just got a
million dollars from him and he was like
um you know i've been through some hard
times and you know i want you to not
have to worry about your kids your
mortgage or school whatever it is um you
know here you go enjoy and i was like
that is a baller move i love that why
haven't i heard this story before i
think that's kind of amazing
and that actually is uh comes to a point
i've actually been reading about this
lately so there's this great book and
this concept called die with zero have
you heard of this
no but i get the idea just off the title
so it's a good title yeah so it's called
die with zero and the idea that we all
have is i wanna try to earn money and
when i die i've got something to give
away to my family if you don't have
family i can give away to causes that i
care about and this whole concept behind
die with zero is why would you do that
and regardless if you believe in heaven
or not i i don't what i think when i i
was like well when i die it's gonna feel
like just how it felt like before i was
born right nothing and how did it feel
like before i was born nothing so do i
really care about a legacy like do i
care about what people are saying about
like tim about me when i'm
you know pre-born feeling right of
course no i don't care so if i'm gonna
and that's not he actually doesn't say
that in the book that's my that's me but
the point of the book is all right why
would you care so much about what what
you're gonna do when you're dead just
give it to people or your friends like
do that plan before you die and enjoy it
with your your friends and family create
a giving plan now if giving matters to
you create a google plan now and do
execute on it now and not when you're
dead right two scenarios scenario one
you wait till you're 88 years old 92
years old you pass away
then there's a will reading and you know
a couple of your friends are there
they're also in their 88 88 to 92 year
old range
uh and your kids are there and their
kids are there whatever and you pass you
know you pass along some money to them
and your 88 year old friend is like oh
thanks for the thanks for the million
dollars george
appreciate it like it'll go straight to
my like you know
yeah you know like what do i need this
for uh and your kids are also like cool
could use that when i was paying off
student debt for years or like wanted to
start a business uh but now that i'm 42
i'm glad that uh
i'm 45 years i'm glad i got this this
inheritance from you thank you
um and so so that's scenario one
scenario two you invite your friends
over for dinner you bring us to me
suitcase with a million dollars in it
and you say
when i eat we all eat let's go and uh
and basically you you hook up the people
who have helped you and it mattered to
you and you helped their lives today
because why wait 40 years and let them
have
more discomfort or suffering along the
way when you could if you're trying to
give to make an impact
impact today is worth a lot more than
impact 45 years from now and um and so
i'm a big believer in this i hadn't
really thought about it until i heard
this george clooney story but when i
heard it i was like oh
and you know my friends if i invite you
to a dinner in a cabin and i show up
with 14 suitcases like you know what's
happening and i'm about to join cleaning
your ass because that's what's going on
and i really have taken this mindset of
of when i eat we all eat um i i really
think it's a lot more fun to to live
that way um the other the other this
little story i'll share
uh i was talking to my trainer and i was
like i was like so uh
i called him jay i was like yo jay so
you like you know about my goals my
dreams you're helping me get there
because you're my coach
like and you talk about like you want to
spin up your business you're starting
this fashion line great like
uh what's your like what is your dream
though like we do this imagination
exercise you know what i'm imagining for
myself and we we love that feeling and
we use that what's yours
and and he has this thing which is you
don't imagine
the outcome so like let's say you wanted
to be rich you don't imagine selling
your company to hubspot and looking in
your bank account seeing x dollars
you imagine like the congratulatory
conversation like once it happens
you won't be so fixated on it happening
your life will just be different because
it happened right so you might imagine
you know um your
call you know you might imagine your
friend calling you congratulating you on
the deal or you might imagine booking a
trip because you have all this free time
now and so you don't imagine the money
you imagine what happens after you had
it and you you know there's the sort of
implied state so anyways his was
oh i imagine getting a text from my mom
saying you know son thank you for the
six thousand dollars this month like
that's huge for me like uh you know i'm
so grateful to have a son like you thank
you so much
and then so he he was talking about that
i was like oh that's cool so instead of
saying i want to be a millionaire so
that i can forgive my mom something he
imagines the text from his mom
and then that got him thinking so the
next day he goes and he sends her six
hundred dollars he's like like i can't
send her six thousand every month right
now but i can send her 600 today and
then he showed me the text he got the
next morning and it was literally like
almost word for word
what he had told me in the garage he was
like she had she texted him she's like
son i don't know what what i did to
deserve such a blessing of a son like
you the money you sent me you don't even
know i needed that uh like it's gonna go
to exactly what i need thank you so much
like you know i love you so much son i
hope you're you know i hope you're doing
well
and i was like damn that was kind of
cool to see it come together and i love
that he didn't wait until it was all
done to start the giving plan all right
so since you were talking about giving
money away i saw that you wrote
something pretty funny in our document
called the jewish hacked to wealth
markets fuzz
i totally agree with you
i have so many by the way i don't even
have more to say that's just kind of it
i have
i've i
my my wife is from a jewish family i've
got a lot of my jewish friends i am so
envious of how the comm and at my
wedding when we all of our jewish guests
they gave us
significant checks
i also think it's a new york thing or i
don't know if it's a new york thing or a
jewish thing but my missouri friends
would give a hundred dollars our jewish
new yorker friends would give a thousand
dollars right and it was amazing and i
think that there's something in the in
in that particular community where you
give a significant amount of money for
gifts so you can help one another out
and and money kind of flows a little bit
more freely
getting eight or five thousand dollars
or something when you're 16 years old or
15 years old i've talked to some kids
that's like how a lot of like
interesting businesses have been started
they said the user bart mitzvah money
i completely agree
[Laughter]
yeah i uh i don't know how many jews
there are in the world i think there's
like 10 million jews something like that
like like 20 i think 14
yeah something like that 14 20 million
not a lot but jewish people have they
punch above their weight they have a lot
of impact they have a lot of power they
have a lot of success
and i don't think it's genetic i think
it's cultural i think basically there's
a strong foundation of basically like
helping each other out so everything
from birthright right like a free
basically all expense paid trip
to your home country
at one point in your life that's kind of
an amazing program and that keeps the
instead of the brain drain and people
just sort of like leaving and not having
this like
emotional tie to the culture
no that one transformed experience keeps
people tied in
um there's you know bar mitzvah right so
like i have i don't know how many times
i've heard
yeah i just took all my bar mitzvah
money and uh i used that to like start
the business or i used that to like
start investing in the stock market and
like like my buddy he had i think
i don't feel like 12 grand or something
like 10 grand from his bar mitzvah
uh like money something like that like
when he was whatever i don't know how
old you are 13 or something when it
happens
and by the time we were in college he
was like
he's like got a [__] portfolio of a
quarter million dollars and i'm like
what how do you have all this money he's
like oh yeah it's just been compounding
for for you know for for 10 years
basically
and he's like yeah one of the guys you
know our family friend who gave us the
thing he didn't even give me cash he
gave me straight stock of this one
biotech company uh that he really
believed and the biotech company has
like 10xed in the seven year period
and uh yeah so like i have you know what
do we want to do i got 200 000 if we
wanted to start a business and i was
like man what a hack and so two things i
think it's amazing
i think more culture should do this
i also had heard a pretty interesting
idea of like you know universal basic
income
so it's like this idea of like
every year you give people some amount
of money ten thousand dollars a year or
whatever i don't know what the proposed
numbers are but some amount of money is
your universal basic income like social
security for all people
um and it's like pretty expensive and so
some people think it's great some people
think it's bad i don't really know i
don't really care
but i do think this other idea i heard
was better which was um what if you got
a birth dividend so let's say every u.s
citizen when you're born
um the government or whoever puts 2 500
in your account could be 2500 or 5 000
something like that
so from age zero to and you can't touch
it until you're 21.
um
so age zero to 21 you uh you have this
thing compounding and if something's
compounding over 21 years
it's going to you know double probably
at least i think three times so three to
four times
and so you know everybody walking out at
21 years old would have 15 to 20 20 000
um
ready for them to to do whatever they
want as a as a cushion for life as a way
to start something as a way to fund a
creative pursuit if they want to be an
artist or whatever
and i thought that was a pretty powerful
idea and like a great
sort of one-time bonus for every citizen
and then it's invested so it's actually
fueling the economy um so it's not like
universal basic income where you get it
you might save it you might spend it you
don't know what you'll do but it's going
to be invested in like an index for for
21 years
and then in doing that everyone is uh
bought into a particular type of thing
and so
that way even if you have um different
opinions so i think that we should do
this i think we should do that that's
cool but at least we all have a little
bit even just a tiny bit of skin of the
game and so we're incentivized in a
similar way and everybody would learn
about investing and compounding and like
the the benefit of of time in market uh
right time and market is the most
important thing right there's the
buffett phrase time in market is over
but i i take that over timing the market
and so if you once you've been in the
market for 21 years and you look at that
account and you get to see it going up
you're gonna like realize the value of
investing and that that's you know like
the true path to to wealth if you just
do more of that whereas if you never get
started
then you never really feel it real and
so i think that's a big
benefit i think we should have the
american but mitzvah fund
that's actually a great idea that's
that's that's that's incredibly
interesting um all right maybe we want
to do one last one
um
tell me about aubrey de grey because uh
i i've known a little bit about this
i've known a little bit about him i've
listened to podcasts with this guy i
believe he's an he's an anti-aging
doctor and professor
yes so
this is a funny story i find it funny
other people are gonna be like how could
you say that's funny the funny it's
ironic i went on twitter last night
as i do and i see
this tweet that says aubry de gray is a
sexual predator
i don't know who aubrey de gray is so
i'm like but that's a bold tweet okay
what are you talking about so you know
my my
my gossip the gossip part of me starts
starts getting excited so i click it i
start trying to see what's going on and
basically two things happened
i found out that this person audrey de
grey has
you know kind of like i don't know
exactly what they've done but made
people feel uncomfortable at the least
and maybe sexually harass people at the
most i'm not 100 sure but basically two
women who were who are in that field
laura denning and
i forgot the other person's name
they came out yesterday or recently this
week something like that and they
published stories saying aubrey to gray
you know made me feel uncomfortable
maybe you know said things to me that
were totally inappropriate abusive power
and
the organization that funds him knew
about this covered it up because he was
so important for fundraising and for the
science of this because he's been
basically like a lifelong
uh
leader of this movement of of anti-aging
so i see that then i'm like all right
who's this i just want to see what he
looks like what was his zombie degree
guy he's got this huge beard have you
seen him yes he looks like um
a little bit like uh there was a what's
the famous uh philosopher from the
soviet union no uh not nostradamus
rasputin yeah yeah yeah yeah he looks
like you know gandalf or dumbledore or
something like that you know he looks
like you know of that lineage you know
he you wouldn't be surprised if he's
dumbledore's cousin so he uh i i see him
and i'm like oh that's interesting
what's this guy like all about uh what
is he a big deal and i i click and i so
two things one i click and i listen to
this ted talk and ironically the
funniest thing in the ted talk was at
the end somebody asked a question
uh and they go
if you're so into anti-aging why do you
try to look like an old man
that was hilarious um the second the
thing is this guy is pretty fascinating
very charismatic very weird
and very interesting and the whole topic
of anti-aging is fascinating and so
i know yesterday was like he's getting
canceled and like you know he probably
did some [__] up things i don't really
know the guy's character maybe he's a
bad guy i have no idea
but this topic of anti-aging and that
was ironic that that was my entry point
into it but i was blown away by what's
going on in this field so i wanted to
kind of share this with you i basically
wanted to like summarize this guy's ted
talk
uh for you in like two minutes um so he
gives his ted talk back in 2005 and he's
talking a million miles a minute i talk
fast he talks
ten times faster than me
and he's got these slides that are the
white with black text and then like red
font callouts of like his opinion uh so
he took like you know 12 minutes to make
these slides but they're actually very
effective at communicating
and so he he basically gives us talk he
goes
um
aging and illness and death are you know
uh people think today that these are
um inevitable and that they are okay and
that they're good um i don't think any
of those things are true i do not think
it's inevitable i think we will defeat
aging i think we'll we'll be able to
live thousands of years
i do not think they're good and i do not
um i think we should just sit by and
just let let you know 150 000 people die
every day
that was like how he starts right so
you're like okay tell me more he's like
first i'm going to tell you about
the bad arguments against what i'm
trying to say right by the end of this
i'm going to convince you that it's not
only possible it is probable that we're
going to do this um and i'll tell you
how
but before that i'll convince you i'll
let me get rid of some of these really
bad arguments he's like bad argument
number one um
oh we'd be so bored if we didn't die
right uh bad argument number two is
oh the population will get too big uh
and
humans are bad for the earth or whatever
right he goes through these arguments he
kind of like debunks each one of them
very quickly
he's basically like look what we want to
do is we want to be healthy for a long
time right we're not just trying to be
old and like dependent and feeble for a
long time we want to be healthy for a
long time
and he's like here's what's going on in
this field and so this was kind of just
for me i didn't know any of this so he's
like there's two schools he's like first
why do we die
and he's like why do we die we die for
two reasons he's like
to live our body does all these
metabolic processes basically like
heating your body cooling your body
immune system digesting food like
you know learning growing building
muscle uh all these are metabolic
processes
we do them to live and just like any
machinery like a car or a factory the
more you use the machinery the more like
the as the physics of the thing moving
happens damage happens over time it
accumulates and eventually the thing
breaks and stops working
so he goes living creates damage
damage is happening all the time and
then eventually the damage kills your
cells and then you die
and he's like all right so
there's two schools of thought school
thought number one is that
let's stop the damage
prevent damage right prevention is
better than the cure and he's like
bad idea we barely even know how
metabolism works
and it's highly unlikely that you're
going to be able to keep the high
function of the machine running and like
stop damage from happening damage seems
kind of like inevitable
um if the machine's gonna run
and he's like that's called whatever one
school of thought doesn't matter what
this call what the name is he's like
there's another called geriatrics a
geriatrics basically is like
cool damage happens but how do we like
either repair damage or uh or like limit
the damage so that it doesn't kill your
cells
and he's like that's where i think this
is gonna work so here's like this guy's
case on how this is going to work he
goes
we are going to reach a point where we
have a therapy called human rejuvenation
rejuvenation therapy hjr
i think rhr
hrt or something like that i don't know
what he calls it human rejuvenation
therapy let's just call it that for sure
he's like basically you're gonna he's
like what we know is that
you're living by the way is this boring
or should i keep going no i'm looking at
uh i'm looking at what he's saying now
as you go keep going okay so so
basically he's saying like he's like one
thing we notice is that the damage is
happening from the day we're born right
your cell's function you damage but you
don't really feel the effects until
you're like middle-aged or getting older
so 40 50 60 that's when you start to the
damage starts to accumulate the cells
start to die and that's when brain
function slows down muscle function
slows down reaction time slows down he's
like so it there's this like point where
there's too much damage so we need to
give you a therapy before then he's like
we can't just like modify your dna so
there's no damage happening what we need
to do is by the time you're 30 or 40 we
need to be able to give you something
that's gonna like repair the damage
that's happening uh faster than the
damage is happening
and he's like that's how we're gonna
solve this
number two we're gonna solve it first in
mice before we solve it in humans he
goes mouse lives two years
the test is gonna be can you get the
mouse to live five years but here's the
trick you can't breed the mouse
differently
you have to let the mouse live normally
for 18 months and then you have to give
them something at 18 months that extends
life by two years
that's going to be the test and he's
actually put up like a million and a
half dollar prize or whatever like
there's a multi-million dollar prize for
anybody that can do that you have to do
a test where it's like an x prize it's
like let a mouse live for 18 months give
him a therapy and now his life needs to
be extended and in the control where you
don't give the mouse the thing he needs
to die six months later as planned
and um so that's like the that's the
breaking point he's like once we figure
out how to do that then like 10 15 20
years later or something like that we'll
be able to translate that into humans
but we don't know how to do it in mice
yet
um he's like right now we can extend
their life a few months but not years
he goes the second thing
people think that this is really far
away like oh yeah maybe people will live
forever but not in my lifetime
he goes what the way that science works
is he has this curve he shows like
if you were 80 years old and we discover
this [__] it's too late for you you're
dying
if you're 60 years old and we discover
this [__] it's kind of too late for you
you're dying if you're 50 and we
discover it we might extend you
by a good 30 years
but you're probably gonna die at that
point he's like but if you're 40 or 30
and we discover this and like when at
the time when we discover this
you like have escape velocity as i call
it meaning i'm going to give you the
therapy before enough damage has
happened and you're going to live
like the guy who's 10 years older than
you is going to live till he's 150 and
you're going to live till you're a
thousand
he's like that blows people's minds but
it's true it's just the way that this
works which is once we have the therapy
the difference between somebody living
an extra 40 or 50 years and an extra
thousand years will just be like
a 10-year age gap because you'll be just
below that threshold damage how far away
are we
and so he's like the part he's then he
just discusses the science of
breakthroughs he goes
in every field there are breakthroughs
breakthroughs are extremely hard to
predict when they happen he's like
flight even you know from prehistoric
ages we've had this idea of being able
to fly
and nobody knew how to fly until like
1903.
1903 the wright brothers figure out
how to fly
and then from there it's like every 25
years there's like a pretty big jump
from
two dudes in a plane that's basically
gonna kill you to like a plane that's
reliable to a plane that can go really
far to supersonic planes to like now we
get on a plane it's super safe you go to
sleep you watch a movie and you fly
right like every 25 years incremental
progress happens after the breakthrough
but you so you can predict incremental
progress
so he knows after we get the
breakthrough of figuring out mice we're
going to have like 15 20 years before we
get it to to be a therapy in humans that
extends life 20 or 30 years a healthy
life
um but
uh you know we don't know when that
breakthrough's gonna happen he's like
the bad part is it's been like 100 years
and basically nothing's happened uh for
this breakthrough and so uh so yeah so
that's where that's kind of like where
it's at right now but i was pretty
fascinated i was like i want to go this
is just like a like i'm at the ted talk
level so like you know that's the
surface of the surface but i'm very
interested in going deeper and learning
more so there's this book on longevity i
believe it's called lifespan i'm i'm
thinking about reading it i'm very
fascinated by this too it it something
that i've been thinking about and we're
going to wrap up here it's all like when
i was thinking about dying it seems like
we mostly like all just die from like
some type of cancer or alzheimer's or
something like that like we like if the
timeline's long enough like we're all
gonna get cancer or like some type of
alzheimer's or something like that and
die and i've always been wondering to
myself
isn't it weird to you that with
everything that we have that someone
could still die from one of these
illnesses that you could have you could
have had for six 12 24 months like i've
always thought like you should know
right away you should know like once
that cell forms or you know i don't know
anything about medicine but you
understand and so anyway this is i've
also been obsessing with that maybe it's
because like i'm getting in my my 30s
now and i'm like well i kind of i'm very
slowly but i kind of just felt like a
little bit of like soreness i don't want
to like get older and i'm flipping out a
little bit so i'm on board with this i'm
going to start reading this
yeah there's um
there's uh
uh what's it called
there's this chart that's great and the
chart basically shows why do people die
it's like it's like a visual chart so
it's like uh blue if it's um
you know it's it just happens in
yourself it's non-transmissible red is
if one person passes it to another like
the flu or covet or whatever
and then there's like a the size of the
bubble is basically how many people die
of that every year it's like number one
is cardiovascular disease and then
number two is cancer and that's like you
know that's bulk of the deaths right and
then like number five is influenza and
then you kind of you know whatever you
go on from there so you're right it is
these sort of same causes stuff that
people are trying to fix
but uh no no breakthrough yet that like
just radically eliminates that like
remember when people used to die of
cancer that will happen it's just a
matter of when uh which is pretty sweet
honestly yeah it's interesting to me um
all right i think that uh that episode
was a nine out of ten what do you think
i liked it what do you think dan i give
you a nine as well
all right i think that was good
um dan's got a little bit of a ned
flanders in him i could see dan being
the ned flanders of a neighborhood
i don't think that's a compliment
great neighbor what's wrong with dead
flanders all right i'll take it like a
very positive guy yes that i thought
that was a comment all right thank you
that's the episode
i feel like i can rule the world
travel never looking back